these handheld enclosed pizzas are
compact enough for kids to easily hold
their baked then immediately frozen so
they require no preservatives and all
the ingredients are organic one main
ingredient is cauliflower while having
little impact on flavor it packs a
strong nutritional punch low in calories
it's an excellent source of several
vitamins and minerals and dietary fiber
it also helps thicken the filling after
removing the stems the cooks boil the
cauliflower heads until tender then
remove them from the pot with a slotted
spoon to let the water drain away they
puree the cauliflower in a food
processor
The Cook's also boil and puree butternut
squash which is chock-full of vitamin A
vitamin C and many other nutrients the
squash puree adds sweetness to the
filling and also helps thicken it
the other filling ingredients are tomato
paste parmesan and mozzarella cheeses
potato flakes sea salt and spices and
water after measuring out the required
amounts workers pour the ingredients one
by one into a large fat they blend the
ingredients not with an electric mixer
but manually with a large whisk to keep
the texture course the ingredients for
the pizza dough are wheat flour
unbleached all-purpose flour baking soda
and palm fruit shortening which provides
the fat that makes the dough pliable
they add water then blend the
ingredients in a mixer for how long is a
company secret and it's the critical
factor that determines the dough's
texture they also won't reveal how long
or at what temperature they let the
dough rest once it's ready the next step
is to transform the blocks of dough into
sheets for making the pizzas they place
a block which is about 20 centimetres
thick on the dough sheeter the dough
moves back and forth beneath the roller
until it's flattened into a sheet
a fine dusting of flour prevents the
dough from sticking to the roller once
the dough sheet is just the right
thickness they wind it on a spool the
operator transfers the spool to the
processing line which unwinds the sheet
to begin making the pizzas for rotary
blades trim the sides and divide the
sheet into three strips spray nozzles
lightly moisten the dough with water to
make it more pliable at perfectly timed
intervals a depositor dispenses the
thirty three grams of filling per pizza
on one side of each strip then the
Machine lifts and folds the other side
over a crimping wheel seals the edge to
encase the filling a sprinkle of flour
prevents the dough from sticking to the
crimper and rotary cutters which trim
off the excess dough finally a chopping
blade descends to separate the filled
dough into individual pizzas and a
crimper seals the third edge
workers transfer the pizzas by hand onto
baking sheets lined with parchment paper
to prevent sticking the company won't
divulge how long the pizzas bake in the
oven but it will say that as soon as
they come out they're flash-frozen
this rapid deep freeze locks in the
nutrients and makes adding preservatives
unnecessary